so let's talk about what's happening on
the Republican side there were also
Republican primaries over the weekend
the narrative has been Donald Trump
cannot be beaten Donald Trump is
dominating Donald Trump is sailing to
victory and nobody's going to be able to
stop him unfortunately this pesky thing
called math does not reflect that
narrative let's first talk about Louis
the actual Republican primaries over the
weekend you will notice that in Kansas
Ted Cruz handily defeated Donald Trump
you will notice that in Kentucky Trump
won but only barely over second-place
finisher Ted Cruz you will notice that
in Louisiana Donald Trump won but again
only barely over Ted Cruz and in Maine
Ted Cruz coming away with a pretty solid
victory over Donald Trump 46 233 so
Donald Trump did win two states barely
while Ted Cruz handily won two states
Kansas and Maine so although the
narrative continues to be one of Trump
utter domination the Republican race is
way closer than people seem willing to
admit particularly the Trump supporters
Louis let's look at the delegate math so
far on the Republican side the eventual
nominee will need 1237 delegates to
secure the nomination Donald Trump is in
the lead with about thirty one percent
of the delegates he needs to secure the
nomination but Ted Cruz is right there
at 24 and a half percent twenty four
point four percent of the delegates he
needs for the nomination so Louis map
tells us no matter what it is Trump
wants you to believe no matter what it
is the Trump supporters want you to
believe Donald Trump is barely ahead
here and the longer Marco Rubio goes
without closing the gap and there's no
evidence Marco Rubio is going to be able
to close the gap the more Rubio
supporters are going to go towards Cruz
this is no great victory because Ted
Cruz is far crazier than Donald Trump
but but this is not the overwhelming
Trump runaway that we're hearing some
talk about no I mean nationally
according to the polls if you want to
talk about polls Trump still looks
pretty good uh but and and Rubio should
just drop out now but you're right uh
I'm not gonna say that this is certainly
going to be a trump victory and let me
be clear when I say if I knew that the
Republican would win I would rather
Trump I don't say I'd rather Trump
because I love Trump's ideas what I am
saying is Trump's campaign is far more
of a farce that has been effective at
coalescing some of the ugliest elements
of the Republican Party don't get me
wrong Ted Cruz believes the insanity
that he says he believes and his family
believes that he was anointed by God to
be President of the United States to
bring about the second coming of Christ
if I knew it was going to be a
Republican in the White House Trump's
delusional ideas are just not going to
get very far it's it's broadly speaking
concocted Louis Ted Cruz really scares
me in a genuine way yeah I I just
someone who actually has those ideas the
thought of them speaking to world
leaders uh and world leaders of
different religions and world leaders
who are not religious at all I don't
like the idea of that i I really don't
although the idea of reality star Donald
Trump uh being involved in those
meetings isn't the glorious idea either
but over the odd we we have to
distinguish between the type of
candidate that Cruz's versus trump
drastically drastically different the
online news world is getting pretty
cluttered with lots of nonsense there's
the so-called news sites that rewrite
news articles and then there's the
websites we all know that we just can't
trust so lately i've been reading
smashpipe which is an online magazine
whose goal is to surprise amuse and tell
readers things they don't already know
on a wide range of topics in current
events and culture smashpipe is less
interested in trending topics than in
what's actually going on and smashpipe
has no ads whatsoever other than the
reader generated classified-ad section
and they never will smashpipe is what
happens when
you on a bad day stub your toe on the
miseries and mysteries of life check it
out at